gu Rob is asking this is an interesting
one uh how do you market products to
customers who hate the products what's
your strategy um I think you probably
need in that girl I think if they really
hate the products you've got to find out
why you got to put number one obviously
upset go where the audience is put
yourselves in their shoes ah and then
there's some great ways again through
social media to find out exactly why
they don't like the product and then
back to iteration test driving and the
product development re-engineer the
front to make sure they do like it and
you know i think these days the product
is so much more than just a practice the
brand is the customer service is the
partnership network is so many different
things that are part of a pro at these
days that um i think it's really
important that you kind of get a
understanding of all the elements of the
sort of pratt mix to make sure that you
land it better and again I would know
don't beat yourselves up you know
Garrett I I beat myself up probably too
much and and with any company I you
never should be satisfied you always
want to do more but you should savor the
moment of what you got and even if you
got a product out there with customers
the reality is you've probably done
pretty well to get it to that stage but
then the next stages get new customers
to become raving fans so I think they
are I don't know you know reality your
customers they're just human beings they
want to love your product to love your
company and if you start believing that
then you're on a mission to let them be
incredibly happy and big kind of net
promoters a big advocates um and big
ambassadors and they're part of the
volunteer army that you pray I think if
you have products that customers hate
you need to stop marketing and start
listening and retool the product right
that like you just stop spending money
trying to get new customers in if your
current customers are really unhappy
just listen to your customers and make
them happy make the product better hey
actually having I'll tell you those toys
so um 1998 in my startup company
and we built it we thought as an awesome
product the engineers were great down in
California and then we actually ship the
product to a few customers out on the
East Coast and one of the customers in
Wilmington at Chuck they're pretty big
brand name I probably not appropriate to
tell you who they are but they picked up
the phone to me one day and said you
know your product sucks and it was in
the call center and and I said look I'll
fly there and fix whatever whatever it
takes because it's really important we
get you home and make you really happy
that we've done the right thing for your
business and I met with him and dumb it
is office in the big glass office
there's all these people of the contact
center and when when the contact center
went down in those days this is kind of
pre-internet so this is when there was
really old technology and we were
pioneering but when our all these agents
put their hand up it meant some part of
the system had gone down and I'll
sydney's office glass doors and all
these people putting their hands up and
actually it wasn't related to our
product that their systems had gone down
but he said that's what I'm dealing with
every day and he said and I'll
confiscate he gave me he said every one
second we lose on call costs us three
hundred thousand dollars so what did I
do I went back to California I got all
the engineers together I said guys we
got a big problem we built something we
thought with high integrity was an
awesome product but it's kind of not
it's not it's ro tested we tested the
quality all that stuff but it but it's
not doing the job we expected to do if
so what I said was who's up for going
out to the east coast giving up their
lives I'm making that product work and
we had 20 engineers 20 engineers put
their hand out most sense they said the
dirt and literally I'm not kidding you
we put him on a plane they went out
there and they just camped with the
customer in their IT department and they
got that product working now reason why
I'm telling you that it's number one
kind of a core belief I've always had
from a baby really when I was watching
my dad in the business you never let a
customer Dale number to that customer
became a raven advocate fan and he said
you know in the world of technology
technology never works away suppliers
say it well but the great companies make
it work according to what we as the
customer once and then the third thing
wow what a light bulb moment for those
engineers when they came back to
California number one there were rock
stars but they said that was the best
thing we ever did we could never have
imagined how a customer would have used
our product we back here in California
general these clever sort of business
analysis data flow diagram building
product but when you actually see how
customers use your product you've got no
appreciation of how they use your
product until you actually go out there
and you're sitting in the trenches next
to customers seeing it so that comes
back to you know that was an extreme
example but off the back of that heaven
we built 100 million dollar company in
four years I'm sold that product to all
the great institutions Canadian Tire um
you know CIBC MetLife Barclays Bank all
these great companies ah and the product
won awards and those engineers they were
the proudest people in the company and
they they they put a fire out for a
customer and they build a company